hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar applications of ir biotyper
biosurveillance of candida RS and two
tails of salmonella spp I am Megan
Pascal of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Brooker deltonyx to learn more visit
broker.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Dr
Daisy Contreras clinical associate at
Cedar Sinai Medical Center in Los
Angeles California
Dr Contreras you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for that introduction
and thank you for the opportunity to
host this webinar and share the
different applications that we have been
exploring within our clinical
microbiology laboratory here at
Cedars-Sinai with a focus on our Canada
auras two-tier diagnostic algorithm
surveillance program and how the IR
biotyper helped us in our salmonella
investigation case that I will share
with you later on in the second part of
of the talk
I hope after sharing some preliminary
data and some of the application routes
that we took with this new technology
that it opens up the Horizon for other
Laboratories to begin and explore the
different applications as we continue to
do here in the laboratory
this is a brief outline of what I'm
going to be focusing on throughout my
talk two main applications that I will
be discussing today
is how the IR biotyper was used for
fungal strain typing as part of our
second tier
in our two-tier diagnostic algorithm for
our Canada RS surveillance program here
at Cedars-Sinai with a special focus on
first asking the initial questions of
does it even have the discriminatory
power to distinguish between clinically
significant fungal pathogens
the second application is how the IR
biotyper aided in our salmonella case
that was recovered in two distinct
separate stem cell culture
and it's rolled in
salmonella strain typing
I have no disclosures I have nothing to
disclose
before I begin my talk let me briefly
introduce our Hospital
I'm sure most of you are familiar with I
work at Cedar Sinai Medical Center known
to most of you as a hospital to the
stars in beautiful Beverly Hills
we are a 980 bed facility
it is one of the major surrounding
hospitals and multi-specialty academic
Health Science centers in the Los
Angeles area our microbiology laboratory
serves the main Medical Center as well
as our affiliate Mourinho Del Rey
Hospital which is a 200 bed Community
surgical hospital along with our
countless Outreach and outpatient
clinics the microbiology laboratory is a
24 7 days a week
365 days a year service laboratory we
roughly have a little bit over 555
full-time employees that include both
Clinical Laboratory scientists as well
as mlas we handle around a little bit
over 6 000 specimens per week and all of
the sub-specialties including virology
molecular microbiology bacteriology both
aerobic anaerobic we have a full service
B cell 3
mycobacteriology laboratory where we
handle all of our all of our MTB work as
well as some of the emerging pathogens
work that we've been seeing lately which
is great for us
we have a full service mycology
laboratory where you know this is where
we actually encounter these nasty bugs
such as Canada RS
what is Canada RS you might ask I'm sure
everyone here listening in this webinar
is very familiar with this nasty
organism
Canada auras is a multi-drug resistant
fungal pathogen with some strains
resistant to all three classes of
anti-fungals including your azles your
echina candins and your polyens
it was first reported in 2009 following
the isolation from an ear canal hence
the name Aris of a patient in Japan
retrospective studies of three
unidentified yeast cases in South Korea
in 1996 identified one of the cases as
Canada auras making it the earliest
known case on record so as you can see
it dates back
as far back as 1996.
superbug has been primarily associated
with invasive and nosocomial infections
such as candidemia but has reported to
cause central nervous system respiratory
urogenital skin and soft tissue as well
as bone infections as you can see it
holds and represents a wide spectrum of
disease
on the other spectrum of infection is
colonization especially in patients and
long-term acute care hospitals and
skilled nursing facilities primary sites
of colonization include the actual groin
but has been found to be colonized in
the narrates and rectum as well
literature shows that Canada RS can be
isolated for up to three months after
initial infection even if the infection
has cleared therefore allowing it to
easily spread among the most vulnerable
of our patient population
here I have a picture of a global map
taken from an article from current
opinion in microbiology published in
2019 and I think this figure this
illustration really highlights This
Global spread of this superbug
beginning in 2009 where you only really
saw Canada RS infections concentrated in
Japan and South Korea which those were
the first reported cases and then over
time as people traveled and as you know
the world is connected and we are all
joined as one and eventually it came
across and travel across the continents
by 2015 which was the first reported
case in the U.S all the way to 2018
where you really can't see the distinct
distinct spread of Canada are as
globally
phylogenetic studies of these isolates
have identified five predominant strain
populations belonging to different clads
having all geographical ties to their
first report
you have your Cloud one which is
referred to your South Asian lineage
your clad 2 which is your East Asian
lineage your clad 3 which is your
African lineage and then your Cloud four
your South American lineage and recently
in 2019 there was a fifth clad of Canada
ours that was identified in Iran from an
ear canal of a girl which shows to be
distinct from the other four lineages
so now that you know the designation of
the different clouds of Canada Ras and
how they were all designated from the
geographical location of origin
let's take a closer look at what is
going on here specifically related to
the U.S
so there was a study conducted by ciao
at all that was published in 2018 that
showed that Canada R is
um
of all four different clouds which
includes your South American Cloud your
East Asian clad your African clad as
well as your South Asian clad have all
been reported throughout the U.S
the interesting part is that most of
these cases have been associated with
outbreaks and long-term care acute care
hospitals and skilled nursing facilities
specifically in your metropolitan areas
of New York Chicago California
Etc
in California it seems that the majority
of Canada are as isolates are from the
South Asian lineage but a recent study
that was published in 2020 actually
Illustrated that the primary circulating
strains in the Los Angeles area
specifically have been associated with
the African lineage which is part of the
Class III designation
you might ask what is the importance of
knowing the geographical
um lineage of these Canada auras
um why is that important knowing what
clad your Canada are is isolates within
your patient population is helpful as
especially for susceptibility prediction
modeling for instance strains belonging
to South Asian and African lineage have
higher fluconazole mics when compared to
other lineages
since the first outbreak of Canada RS
was identified in LA county in July of
2020 the number of cases has increased
to over a thousand cumulative cases with
the organism now being considered
endemic to most
skilled nursing facilities or long-term
care hospitals within the county as
shown in the table on the right
the table summarizes case counts by case
and hospital care facility type
approximately nine percent of all LA
County cases had a bloodstream infection
that was found to be attributed to
Canada RS the rest of the cases were
noted to be colonized on the skin and or
in non-sterile sites
the graph on the left on this slide
illustrates the screening program
conducted by LA County Public Health
between June of 2020 to December of 2021
where it shows the screening of over 11
000 Canada RS cases from different
hospital facilities in which they found
that approximately eight percent of
those cases came from colonized
individuals and were identified before
admission to a clinical setting
this really highlights the need for
active surveillance and appropriate
infection prevention strategies at the
hospital level
this prompted our laboratory to develop
a two-tier clinical surveillance
diagnostic algorithm for the enhanced
detection and further prevention of
transmission of Canada RS within our
hospital setting
the first step in this
clinical diagnostic algorithm is for the
active surveillance by rtpcr
the second step is strain typing by the
IR biotyper
both of these steps in this two-tier
diagnostic algorithm assesses the status
of patients being admitted into our
hospital for those individuals
identified to be at high risk for Canada
RS which includes but are not limited to
anyone transferred from a Skilled
Nursing Facility or a long-term care
hospital that seems to be chronically
ventilated with a tracheostomy
the surveillance PCR utilizes the biogx
Canada RS RT PCR reagents for use with
the BD Max open testing system
it utilizes the its2 primer probe set as
set forth in the publication of bleach
at all in 20 published in 2018.
if positive the patient remains in
contact isolation
if negative the patient is removed from
contact isolation any positive Canada RS
surveillance PCR specimen gets reflex to
fungal culture where it gets plated on
inhibitory mold agar and chrome Canada
plus RS plates
once isolated identification is
confirmed by moldy Toff the isolate then
gets full
antimicrobial susceptibility testing
utilizing the yeast 1 assay micro
dilution platform
and in parallel the isolate goes through
the second step of our diagnostic
algorithm which is strain typing by the
IR biotyper
but before I get into the second tier of
our diagnostic Canada aura's algorithm
the surveillance PCR was found to be
highly specific and sensitive
daily PCR testing runs were performed
from an axillo grind specimen collected
from patients admitted with risk factors
risk factors included admission from
Skilled Nursing Facility long-term care
hospital and high-risk patients that are
chronically ventilated or with a
tracheostomy
since the rollout of our surveillance
Canada RS PCR
we have successfully screened over 2400
and more high-risk patients and have
found a positivity rate of colonization
of around four percent
which has been found to play a critical
role in infection prevention and
transmission of this elusive pathogen
in addition to Rapid identification of
colonized patients an alternative to
strain typing method was needed to Aid
in real-time outbreak investigations
within our clinical setting
in this context the laboratory turned to
spectroscopy-based techniques
particularly setting focus on the IR
biotyper
the IR biotyper utilizes mid infrared
radiation associated with Fourier
transformed IR spectroscopy
this Direct
IR radiation infrared radiation
generates vibration patterns primarily
in the co stretching of biomolecules
such as carbohydrates within the
biochemical structure of these
prokaryotic cells
these vibration patterns generate strain
specific absorbance fingerprints within
the infrared Spectrum which can be used
to differentiate among isolates
literature has shown extensive reports
illustrating the discriminatory power
among gram-positive gram-negative
pathogens that are associated with
nosocomial outbreaks within the hospital
setting in regards to the IR typer
biotyper but there is little to no
reports with respect to fungal
strain typing
so our laboratory wanted to see if we
could apply this infrared spectroscopy
technology for its utilization of fungal
strain typing particularly with Canada
RS isolates
from identified PCR positive specimens
any isolated Canada R is strain from an
identified positive PCR specimen would
get plated on Sab Dex agar and incubated
at 35 degrees Celsius for 24 hours to
prepare the isolate for fungal typing
protocol was followed as stated by the
manufacturer with minor optimizations to
fit our laboratory needs
to perform spectral Acquisitions
specimen was plated at a minimum of five
replicates on the silicone sample plate
Spectra was recorded using the IR
biotyper spectrometer the recorded
Spectra was then visualized and
processed by the Opus version 8.2
software
to expand on the differences between the
Spectra of different isolates the second
derivative of each of the isolates were
performed using client software version
3.0
standardization of media type
temperature and incubation time allows
for interpretation
and processing of specimens at different
time points
following specimen preparation the
average time from processing to result
is approximately three hours
on this slide you can see
some of our preliminary data
a disclaimer to this is that we used
whole genome sequencing
to assess the validity of the spectral
data analysis and not as a strict
comparator method
so all of the data and conclusions that
we derived from the IR biotyper analysis
were supported by whole genome
sequencing
so the questions we wanted to ask here
was we first wanted to test the
discriminatory power of the IR biotyper
among different clinically relevant
yeast species including Canada albicans
Canada Labrada Canada RS and
cryptococcus neoformance
hierarchical cluster analysis allowed
for the successful differentiation of
different yeast isolates which form
distinct clusters both at the genus and
species level as shown here on the slide
one of the many advantages of client
software version 3.0
on the IR biotyper is that you can
analyze and view your data in many
different ways
on this slide we have a principal
component analysis of the normalized
second derivative of each of the Spectra
for each of the isolates
here the principal component analysis
plot is illustrating the successful
differentiation
of the different clinically significant
yeast isolates which again are found to
be aggregating or clustering based on
the differences at both the genus and
species level
this is another example of the
advantages of the client software
version 3.0
it is a very versatile platform that
allows the user to visualize and analyze
the data using different techniques
here is the same 2D principle component
analysis plot that was shown in the
previous slide but now I'm illustrating
the data in a three-dimensional space
which again is showing the clustering of
these clinically significant fungal
isolides based on both the genus and
species level
now that we were successfully able to
differentiate among these different
fungal species we wanted to really look
at a closer look and assess the
variability and similarities among the
identified Canada RS isolates which I
will go into the next slide
so we took a subset of the isolated
Canada RS isolates and process them
according to our protocol as discussed
earlier in the presentation
Spectra acquisition was acquired by the
IR biotyper spectrometer and its
normalized second derivative was
analyzed using client software version
3.0
this data was then referenced
to whole genome single nucleotide
polymorphism-based phylogenetic analysis
of the Canada auras sequence genomes
this analysis showed the assignment of
the two of two subset of Canada RS into
two distinct lineages
the majority of Canada are as isolates
were closely related to African lineage
or clad III
apart from a single Canada R is isolate
that was found to be genetically
distinct
the single isolate replicate cluster was
closely related to a Canada RS isolate
from the South Asian lineage that
belonged to the cloud one
IR based Spectrum typing analysis of the
Canada RS isolates confirmed the
separation of the two specified clusters
clusters 3 as shown on the slide
demonstrates isolates belonging to the
African lineage and cluster 4.
the single isolate cluster belonging to
the South Asian clad
furthermore phylogenetic camera analysis
of Canada are as isolates in cluster 3.
to its closest ancestral relative showed
less than 30 snip difference among the
strains
which contain isolates from both the
main hospital and its Affiliated
clinical Center
IR Spectra typing analysis distance
Matrix supported the whole genome
reference data
in that the majority of circulating
Canada are as strains are genetically
very similar suggesting that population
genetics are geospatial specific in
origin with subsequent spread making
transmission within a hospital setting
very hard to definitively conclude
without any additional epidemiological
data supporting that conclusion
clusters were defined by
either admission from a specific Skilled
Nursing Facility or from a specific
long-term care hospital that the patient
had transferred from or had been
residing for a long period of time
before being admitted into our hospital
setting
this slide is showing you another way of
visualizing your data within the client
software version 3.0 on the IR biotyper
I'm a visual person so this actually
helps me picture and clearly see the
separation between the two lineages that
we observed from the subset of Canada
are as isolates that was shown in the
previous slide
this is clearly showing a distribution
of a single cluster belonging to the
South Asian lineage and then the
majority of the isolates clustering
together
um which are all belonging to that
predominant La strain that is currently
circulating that derives from the
African lineage
the next steps that we are currently
moving towards is can we take this
classifiers this data regarding Cloud
distribution within our patient
population and utilize the AI artificial
intelligence feature in the new software
and see if we can come up with
predictive modeling where we can keep
track of these clad distributions within
our patient population and then in turn
see if there's any Trends or shift in
the lineages and how that affects the
susceptibility pattern within the Canada
RS isolates of our patient population
that are currently circulating the Los
Angeles area in real time
overall the two-tier Canada Aura
surveillance diagnostic algorithm
composed of a rapid surveillance
real-time PCR for Rapid detection of the
organism complemented by fungal strain
typing platform for clono prediction
modeling has been proven successful
primarily we were able to show that the
IR biotyper was able to allow for the
successful discrimination of various
dest isolates which included Canada
albicans Canada glabrata Canada RS and
cryptococcus neoformans furthermore the
IR spectrum typing method distributed
the process Canada RS isolates into two
distinct lineages as supported by
phylogenetic genomic analysis of whole
genome sequencing
overall the two key findings that we
were able to
collectively conclude is that isolates
are not clustering based on the hospital
in which they are admitted to but
clustering based on which Skilled
Nursing Facility or long-term care
hospital they are transferring from
given that these isolates are very
genetically similar to one another it
just further supports that there is
currently one huge Canada RS outbreak
that is
plaguing
our Los Angeles County area moving from
one long-term care hospital or Skilled
Nursing Facility to another
second point we were able to conclude
based on this data is that the IR
biotyper has strong discriminatory power
based on the classifier of genomic clad
distribution we were able to identify
two primary lineages that are found in
our patient population and from these
classifiers we can utilize the
artificial intelligence software in the
client software version 3.0 to develop a
predictive model for unknown ongoing
Canada RS isolates that we isolate in
the future from our patient population
so now that you've heard all about our
fungal strain typing application
utilizing the IR biotyper I'm going to
shift gears and percent briefly
about our second application of the IR
biotyper and microbial strain typing
specifically when it comes to salmonella
species
second application of the IR biotyper
was used in an outbreak investigation of
two stem cell cultures growing
salmonella species
this was cause for alarm as you all
probably might feel right now because
these were the very first salmonella
positive stem cell cultures in our
Institution
in which we alerted
um the apheresis and the epidemiological
department which of course prompted a
very quick outbreak investigation
briefly two patients about two months
apart had a stem cell collection in
which cultures from both collection days
were positive for salmonella Group D
the first patient briefly this was a 65
year old woman with history of multiple
myeloma
her stem cell collection was initially
back in January of 2022
and
um she actually presents with
no clinical Illness but has a remote
history of salmonella bacteremia back in
2019.
the second patient which is case two
this was a 45 year old woman with
history of aplastic anemia
her peripheral stem cell collection was
on March of 2022.
she actually had no clinical illness and
no known history of salmonella infection
given the high suspicion of
contamination at either the collection
or laboratory sites epidemia
epidemiology looked at some additional
data such as
did multiple people handle the specimens
actually no samples were transported by
a dedicated lab employee to the
laboratory from the ephristocyte
and samples were processed at separate
times by the dedicated technician
according to standard of practice under
a class II biological safety cabinet
utilizing sterile technique
so all of these additional
epidemiological data was pointing to a
no common source of contact between
these two cultures
furthermore the laboratory aided in the
investigation by performing strain
typing of the isolated salmonella
isolates from these two patient cases
Fourier transform infrared spectroscopy
was utilized to differentiate the
salmonella strains from the two patients
in question when compared to other
salmonella strains isolated it in the
laboratory from prior years
disclaimer whole genome typing data was
used to assess the validity of the
Spectra analysis acquired by the IR
biotyper in this
study as well
based on cluster analysis of the
salmonella species included in the study
the IR biotype are effectively separated
the different zero vars based on their
respective o antigen groups such as
Group D group C1 and Group B
internal validation and cluster analysis
of the data determines the two isolates
from case 1 patient 1A and 1B isolates
were identical but different from the
isolate that grew out of the stem cell
cultures from Patient 2 or case two
the no distance within the cluster
further demonstrated them to be
genomically related but not identical
which was very important
to determine if this was the same strain
during this investigation
so on this slide I'm just showing again
the versatility of client software
version 3.0
um just representing the data from the
previous slide in a principal component
analysis plot that is illustrating the
findings that the salmonella isolates
were found to be Genoa genomically very
related but not the same isolate
this is a distance Matrix which might
sometimes convey more information than
the dendogram but in this case I just
wanted to include this in the
presentation because I wanted to
illustrate that there wasn't much
difference between the salmonella
isolates due to them being genomically
similar
in the case that they belong to the same
zero group and the same subtype but not
the same identical strain
this also prompt us to look at other
parameters other data such as the
susceptibility profile and the
morphological appearance
Etc that distinguishes these two
isolates that were recovered at two
different time points
this was further supported by looking at
other factors on this slide we looked at
the susceptibility profile of these two
isolates that were recovered from both
of these two stem cell cultures and as
you can see
um these two different isolates had a
very different
um
susceptibility profile which further
supported the notion that even though
these were genomically related they were
not the same strain or isolate along
with looking at their susceptibility
profile we also looked at the cultural
morphology of each of the isolates and
data is not shown I'm not showing you
the pictures of the two plates here but
I can assure you that they both have two
different morphologies further again
supporting the notion that these two
were genomically related but not the
same strain
overall taking all of the data together
both the epidemiological data the
susceptibility the morphological data
that I didn't show here but also the
strain typing results that we were able
to acquire from the IR biotyper the the
team was able to dismiss the possibility
of an outbreak and deemed that these two
cases of salmonella positive stem cell
cultures arose from two independent
occurrences and not from a common source
dismissing the idea of an outbreak
situation
overall in our laboratory the IR
biotyper has proven to be a great
alternative method for strain typing
that is moderately priced technically
friendly with post analysis ease that is
easy to use and learn
um and has proven to be a effective
alternative to whole genome sequencing
with this I conclude my talk and I will
be taking any questions at this point
thank you
thank you Dr Contreras for your
informative presentation we will now
start our live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
has your lab Incorporated the IR
biotyper as a diagnostic test alongside
the Candida rspcr
or is it used as a research only use
only
uh that's a good question so right now
we are currently fully validating so all
of the data that was presented was
preliminary data since it's not uh
promoted as a diagnostic tool uh we use
this as a a research use only supplement
to help to help us do some Trend
analysis with Canada R's isolates that
are isolated from our laboratory
therefore creating a predictive model
and kind of doing real time strain
typing in terms of actually
um
doing real-time analysis as you know we
we continue to isolate from PCR positive
uh specimens so right now it's research
use only and is uh or By Request only
either by epidemiology or infection
control
great thank you our next question is how
are you going to identify lineages of
unknown candida RS strains isolated from
your patient's population in real time
so as I previously alluded in the
beginning of the presentation we're
doing this for several different
projects so the new
um
client software that's included in the
IR biotyper
has a machine learning parameter so
we're developing predictive model which
we are applying artificial intelligence
and machine learning
the machine learning uses specific
software algorithms specifically
artificial neural network and support
Vector machine
testing algorithms to make predictions
based on known classifiers so for each
of these separate studies we're
continuing to have three different sets
of of isolates or resource material that
we're using for the Canada R is we have
a train set a test set and a validation
set So based on this trained set of
isolates that we have
we have full uh characterized isolates
based on the lineage they belong to
the Skilled Nursing Facility or
long-term care facility that that they
have transferred from
based on these classifiers we are
training we are using these algorithms
so they can make predictive uh
predictive Notions or predictions based
on that currently we have done the
learning step
now we have moved on to actually testing
some of our isolates which are also well
characterized and then we will plug in
some unknowns
for the salmonella a similar situation
was used in terms of
of machine learning parameters as well
so we used different zero group
classifiers as well as different
stereotypes classifiers so well
characterized isolates that were used to
quote-unquote help the algorithm learn
these classifiers based on these strains
and then we would test the learning of
the instrument and then
um
and then we uh we make prediction
predictions based on that
awesome thank you our next question is
would it be possible to comment on the
regrance used for the IR biotyper
technique is it possible to perform the
technique from broth culture must it be
from Grown colonies on agar the IR
biotyper does identify the species or
should we inform the species on the
software
thank you for that question so yes
um so let me I'll just answer them
according to the order it was asked so
the reagents that were used are reagents
that can be found in your laboratory
that you already have right so we
actually buy a kit from broker itself
where they provide two external controls
that are used
on every run
um those external controls kind of
calibrate the instrument for uh data
acquisition
the isolates
before deciding on what media uh what
standardized media we used we tested a
variety of media including you know your
your Sav decks your IMA and then you're
also your chromogenic agars right to
kind of just uh isolate them isolate the
Canada R's from these PCR positive
specimens once the isolate is uh
confirmed to be Canada R is
we found that septics uh all-purpose
media
non-selective media actually gives us
the best uh replication results
so we stuck to the snapdex media as our
optimized choice of media we incubate uh
overnight we standardize the time of
incubation and the temperature of
incubation at 24 hours at 35 degrees uh
and after that we do isolate
enough biomass from the actual confluent
pure culture plate the biomass has to be
enough it's similar to your maldi
biotype right if there's not enough
biomass then you run into problems with
your your data analysis as well so we've
only tried it from solid media we have
not tried it from uh broth but the
manufacturer does have a broth option if
that's what you would like to take
um we decided that was not part of our
our workflow that we wanted to
incorporate in our laboratory so we've
only optimized growth from solid media
um for this string typing analysis the
IR biotyper you need to have
um you need to have
known well characterized organisms right
so you need to have the identification
uh that they are Canada RS we did
supplement our data with whole genome
sequencing to to make conclusions based
on what we were seeing with the IR
biotyper so we are so using it for
brain typing purposes to make lineage
Trend predictions in the future
um and then if we incorporate other
classifiers this predictive model based
on the machine learning uh
ability of the software these known well
characterized classifiers can then give
you
Insight of unknown strains so basically
you for the initial validation of your
instrument you do have to have
well-classified isolates in order to
develop this predictive model in the
future
all right our next question is besides
the applications presented here has your
lab explored any other venues
yes so we are currently using it for
Canada RS and salmonella
um building and developing a predictive
model but we are also using it for
um we're expanding it to see if we can
utilize the IR biotyper in typing
mycobacteriology obviously
non-tuberculosis strains specific focus
is utilizing the IR biotyper for
mycobacterium abscesses and seeing if we
can create a predictive model based on
Clarithromycin
susceptibility so is the iron biotyper
able to discriminate between
subspecies of M abscesses and based on
that can we make a predictive model to
predict
Clarithromycin or to Aid in the
prediction of Clarithromycin
susceptibility testing
perfect our next question is can the
identification be performed only with
Maldives off MS
though identification can be performed
so yes one of the main the main uh
identification systems that we use in
our laboratory is multitask and I'm sure
that's a similar situation across many
Laboratories right uh
but um you can identify your isolates
any way that your laboratory uses any
workflow uh any identification system
can be used to identify before jumping
into the string typing portion
utilizing the IR biotyper
awesome and it looks like we have one
more question here
um what comparator method was used to
validate the IR biotyper
perfect
um so the comparator method since this
is a different technology right it's
infrared spectroscopy
um so the
comparator it wasn't a strict comparator
method but we did utilize whole genome
sequencing specifically
camera snip analysis was conducted on
each of the isolates that we were able
to
um confirm from our PCR positive
specimens
to validate the conclusions that we were
seeing uh from our Spectra that were
generated by the IR typer
the whole genome sequencing was not used
as a straight straight method competitor
but it was used to validate the
conclusions
great thank you so much Dr Contreras do
you have any final comments for audience
um no I think
um you know given the resources and the
funding and uh you know our laboratory
is always trying to find and utilize new
platforms to answer or fill in gaps
diagnostic gaps uh to help aid in
patient clinical management
um
I think the IR biotyper is a great
alternative it's very cost effective
broker has done a fantastic job at
providing support in terms of data
analysis learning the the software
they've been very very helpful in that
situation they make it easy for us to
ask questions and keep Open Door of
communication and support I think this
is a great alternative the turnaround
time
compared to whole genome sequencing is
actually faster right initially yes you
have to optimize your platform like any
other new assay but once you get an
optimization and you feel comfortable
with the software and you've you
validate your data conclusions
um using an alternative method this can
definitely be a faster uh faster
alternative cost effective uh
user-friendly Tech friendly method to
incorporate real-time strain typing
within your Clinical Laboratory
hello
great thank you so much um it appears we
have a few more questions that popped in
and we do have time to get to these
um
so another question that was asked is at
this time it appears that you were using
whole genome to confirm the results that
are obtained from the IR biotyper
what is the benefit of running the IR
biotype or moving forward will there be
a time when whole genome testing will
not be required and how will you
determine that just IR biotyper testing
is a sufficient method
that's a very good question
um so let me answer the first uh portion
of the question is that yes we did use
whole genome sequencing to validate our
conclusions that were made from the IR
biotyper the benefit to using the IR
biotyper is again
um the user-friendly uh ability to uh to
perform the strain typing right from
from the pre-analytical to the
analytical and to the post analytical
assessment of your data so all of those
components
um from start to finish
takes approximately three hours if you
were doing whole genome sequencing
just alone generating libraries and the
sequencing portion can take up to three
days right also the technical I guess
bottleneck that a lot of clinical
laboratories have right so a lot of
clinical laboratories don't have this
technical ability to perform whole
genome sequencing
by your biotyper is great because
everybody can pipette everybody can
collect uh grow the isolates everybody
has the essential reagents that are
needed there's no extra cost the only
cost is that you do have to you know
there is a kit that broker provides that
is utilized within the whole processing
steps so the isability the cost
Effectiveness
um how it's uh you know the our cls's
um
confidence level and actually performing
the method all of that and the support
the technical support that you get from
broker makes it a great alternative
moving forward so we are trying to
collect enough uh diversity within our
isolates especially with Canada RS and
our salmonella as well as other projects
so we're trying to build our diversity
Library where we can fully internally
validate our machine learning
predictive model where it does cover all
of the lineages all of the classifiers
included in that model that we feel
confident enough where we can say that
yes our validated specimens that are
coming in are the actual uh is what we
actually is is correct right is there's
a high accuracy right now we're still in
the validation portion of it because we
are trying to collect a wide diversity
of
isolates that can cover all aspects of
our classifiers so once we collect a
significant number where we feel
comfortable then we are able to you know
decrease
or not utilize whole genome sequencing
at that point
great and another question we have is do
you have plans to use MRSA stain
analysis
so there is
um plans to move forward to that not at
this point it is in the works we only
have so many hands that are available to
work with in our Clinical Laboratory so
as soon as we find
um you know
time where we can invest in that but
that is in the works that's part of the
the alternative applications that we
have ongoing here
in the laboratory
great thank you so much I'll give it
just a second here to make sure no more
questions pop in
all right thank you so much again Dr
Contreras for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor broker
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us and for their
interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
rates will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye